Speaker 1: I want to tell everybody something
about your cable subscription that you may not
know. Now, I'm not telling you what to do here.
I'm not even sure what to do. And I'll tell you
why. This is a double edged sword. But it's
important that everybody know that if you
have a cable TV subscription with any of the
major cable providers, you are paying Fox News,
you are keeping Fox News afloat. Now it's
a little bit different. When I say that you
are keeping Fox News afloat, then saying you are
keeping HGTV afloat or whatever the case may be,
why is it different? The difference is that Fox
News specifically mostly has deals with the large
cable providers that for each subscriber
they get a significant amount of revenue,
typically almost two bucks a month.
So if you have a cable subscription,
normal cable subscription, you never watch
Fox News. You probably, unbeknownst to you,
are still sending Fox News specifically close
to $2 a month or close to 20 bucks per year.
Now, as we've said before, Fox News, we've been
talking about it all week. Numerous Fox News hosts
have been perpetuating these ideas of so-called
great replacement theory or white replacement
theory. It goes by both names. This was one of the
undergirding foundations of the Buffalo Shooters
Manifesto and the Buffalo Shooters motivation for
going out and seeking black people to kill. Okay,
there's lots of other platforms that are promoting
this stuff as well. The difference is many of
those other ones are online. So like for example,
some of the people promoting white replacement
theory are on YouTube and they make money with
ad revenue. If you don't watch them on YouTube,
you're not giving them any money. Great. The
difference is that with your cable subscription,
even if you don't watch Fox News, you're still
giving them, in many cases, close to two bucks
a month. Now, there's a website I encourage you
to check out called on Fox my cable box dot com.
And it number one tells you the full scope of how
Fox News is funded in this way. And number two, it
allows you to tell your cable provider to separate
out Fox News to make it an optional channel on
just about every cable system. You can't say I
don't want Fox if you don't want to pay for HBO.
On every cable system that I'm aware of, you just
say, I don't want HBO. Great. You don't get HBO
and you don't pay for HBO. On most cable systems,
you can't remove Fox News and Fox Business.
If you pay for cable or satellite TV, you are
subsidizing Fox News. Whether you watch it or not,
the cable provider pays Fox and they pass the
cost directly to you. Now we've said before
I've explained to you Fox doesn't depend that
much on ad revenue. Why not? Because of these
monthly fees from subscribers. When all of those
advertisers bailed on Tucker Carlson's show
and we watched an episode and we saw that he had
almost no advertisers left, and the advertisers
he had left were sort of like a low rent,
low, low value, kind of low brow advertisers,
the mike pillows of the world and stuff like that.
We laughed about it and we had a grand old time,
but we acknowledged that it doesn't really
matter that much because Fox News's revenue model
two thirds comes from subscriber fees
through cable providers. Fox News makes
close to $2 billion a year from these hidden
subscriber fees. That's twice what CNN makes,
and it's three times as much as MSNBC makes.
So, sadly, all of our money, if we have cable,
is being used to fund this extremist programing,
you should not be forced to subsidize Fox News,
but you don't have a choice if you have a cable
subscription. So check out on Fox my cable box,
read about it, fill it out, which will send a
message to your cable provider telling them,
separate this out lot. Allow me to say no.
And that's what we really have to do. I mean,
obviously we can. Also cut the cord.
The sad part about cutting the cord.
While many people have done it and I
don't have any moral opposition to it,
we recently learned that thanks to cord cutting
C-SPAN, which is a very valuable service which
has no ad revenue, C-SPAN has been significantly
hurt by cost cutting. So that's the tragic thing.
You might say, Well, I'll cut the cord to stop
funding Fox. Great. But then you also end up
hurting C-SPAN, which we don't want to hurt.
C-SPAN provides a valuable public service, so
we have to pressure the cable and satellite
providers to stop, including Fox News by default.
You should be able to say, I don't want Fox. And
if you don't want Fox, you shouldn't have to pay
for Fox and the cable provider shouldn't have to
pay for Fox regardless. That's the sort of system
that needs to be upended. We're going to keep you
updated. There's currently negotiations actually
happening right now. Fox and cable providers are
negotiating their next contract on this on these
subscriber fees. And we could really kneecap
Fox News. It's not not a limitation on speech.
Anybody who wants to fund Fox should be able
to. Anybody who wants to watch it should be able
to. Nobody should be silencing Fox. Fox can do
whatever they want, but we shouldn't, by default,
be paying for Fox News when we certainly don't
watch it and absolutely don't want to be funding
it. We'll have more on this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.